this place is the best it's got the air  games prizes here check this out what's  wrong I had a nightmare I was with an  old man he put a helmet on me it's just  a fever get some sleep some beats about  damn time  [Music]  hairs not bad Morty you kind of wasted  your 30s though with that whole  bird-watching phase where's my wife  Morty you were just playing a game it's  called a Braun snap out of it come on  I'm Morty you're Rick look at this you  beat cancer and then you went back to  Cleveland boo it's time to thrash your  bronze core that's the difference  between you and me Morty I never go back  to Cleveland holy [ __ ] this guy's taking  LeBron to go on a sting they just did  another three-peat they didn't have a  single loss